[Music]
gong in the monsterverse has lived quite
alive from being an orphan to the king
of Skull Island from being almost dead
to killing a world-ending robot meca
Godzilla so here in this video we will
Showcase in a timeline everything Kong
has done in the monsterverse in brief so
let's get to it the 1800s the ual dat is
unknown but sometime in the late 1800s
Kong was born his birth was marked by a
tragedy as his parents the loss of their
kind and Skull Island were killed off by
the skull crawlers led by the big one
the skull devil he was hidden under a
pile of rocks and was then left to fend
for himself with only the Eevee people
as his companions 1944 this brings us to
the beginnings of the movie Skull Island
of 2017 where we saw gpe iari and H
Marlo crash land their World War II
fighter planes on SC Island after a
brief dog fight in the air their fight
on land was brought to an end by the
intervention of Kong who was around that
time already a gigantic Beast maybe
somewhere in the size range of 50 to 70
ft in height you know 15 to 21
M
1973 then chronologically we get to the
events of the rest of the movie where a
monarch team investigating the hollow
Earth entry points came into contact
with a juvenile Kong who was by then 104
ft tall or 31.7 M tall then that year C
would battle the skull crawlers again
which were awakened by the seismic
charges dropped by the US soldiers over
the island he would also put an end to
the skull devil finally exacting revenge
for the death of his parents the 1980s
fast forwarding a decade into the future
at some point in the 80s a group of
Shipwrecked people would create a
village in the coast of Skull Island and
Kong would then befriend a young girl
from over there who was eventually
killed by a kraken a deep sea titan that
LS outside the coast of Skull Island
1993 the events of Skull Island animated
series would take place in this year
whereby Kong would finally confront the
gigantic Kraken of the coast of Skull
Island and eventually kill it it is here
that we also get to see that the ancient
Kongs and the Eevee of that Island had
created a civilization in the past with
gigantic structures which was probably
ended by the skull crawlers 995 in the
events of the birth of Kong Comics which
happens in this year Monarch agents
would get St on the island and then
later be saved by Kong Kong here would
Battle the Death of jackals the siren
jaw and a swarm of mother longlegs with
the final battle being against a
gigantic 200t tall Titan a queen mother
long legs by this time Kong had grown to
be around 60 M or 20000 ft tall
himself
2017 the endings of the Monarch series
the first season shows an apex facility
already built in Skull Island where they
welcome the return of the character
stuck in the axis Mundi the reunion was
cut short and was interrupted by a large
Kong coming out of the forest and
roaring with anger at the group of
people there here Kong would have been
around 250 ft or 72 M tall 2019 although
seen in just a glimpse in the monitor
screens K in this year would hear the
call of gidora but as an alpha himself
he would ignore it instead he would hun
down and kill the remaining skull
crawlers that were awakened by the
monster Zero's skull the film's
novelization explains that Kong ignored
gor skull wanting nothing to do with the
Titans and the world Beyond his own
Skull Island
2021 the events of Kingdom Kong takes
place in this year which Kong in the
beginning was seen killing a spirit
tiger that was hunting a team of Monarch
soldiers here Kong would face off
against a Titan called kots who attracts
a Perpetual storm over the island which
was created by Monster Zero and
therefore causing Havoc to skull
Island's ecosystem Kong would defeat the
Titan and sent it back to the hollow
Earth vortex from when it came between
2021 and 2023 sometime between these
years Monarch would pull in a lot of
resources to create a gigantic Dome over
a portion of the island to house the
remaining species of Skull Island K
would also be transferred to live there
in this site and before that he would
have saved an Eevee girl named Gia from
the storm that killed off the entire
tribe by this time Kong would have grown
to the size of 337 ft or 103 m in height
three times what he was in
2024 in this year a few years after the
creation of the Dome the events of
Godzilla versus Kong would take place so
Kong was taken away from that Island in
order to go to the hollow Earth via an
entry point in Antarctica on the way he
is intercepted by Godzilla and they have
their first fight in the ocean he
luckily survives the battle and then
goes on to antara where he gets to the
hollow Earth he then gets into a fight
and kill two War bats that were were
threatening him and the human companions
that were with him he then discovers the
ancestral throne room of the Kongs his
ancient home and gets his battle axe he
would then later be drawn back to the
surface to Hong Kong by Godzilla and
they would have a second battle which he
would lose again almost dying but
revived and surprisingly helps Godzilla
later to defeat Mecca Godzilla
effectively killing Mecha G between 2025
and 2028 so in the upcoming gxk the
hunted Comics which will be set after
2025 Kong would be living his life in
the hollow Earth still searching for
other members of his species wherever
they are during that time he will be
hunted by a person who has already
collected quite a few trophies of the
species of Skull Island and then seeks
to get his hands on the king the Kong
also there in the story line he would
battle a couple of monsters including a
feline Titan which looks like a cross
between a monkey and a cougar maybe it's
a
mil and 2028 now now finally in this
year we will get Kong and Godzilla again
teaming up to fight Titans that are way
above their pay grate Kong here would
find an entire tribe or an army of other
Kongs members of his own species but
they would all be under the tyranny of
another ape titan called scar King in
order to defeat this red ape and his
Titan companion shimu K would have to
seek an alliance with Godzilla and maybe
other Titans to deal with this world
ending threat as for the size of Kong as
of this time he might still have the
same height or even if he grows he'll
still be under 350 ft or 17 M tall so
that's all we have about Kong in brief
as of the current setting now if you
like this video then watch this other
one as well and do check out our channel
for other monsterverse content we might
have things you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam